setting expectations setting the right
goals is very important because i found
myself too competitive and from time to
time even when i won some competitions
if i didn't achieve my my personal goal
i found myself winning in competition
but not satisfied enough
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started this episode is powered by j
ventures a community driven vc fund in
silicon valley in partnership with
lomitek and sponsored by homework
ventures hippo insurance opposed hillel
stanford leap and birthright excel an
immediate partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm joined by ilan pelleg
the co-founder and ceo of lightrun elon
used to be professional athlete who
represented israel in the biggest
international scenes out there he
retired at the age of 21 and started his
first entrepreneurial journey with his
partner leonid they founded homie food
which was a small israeli startup that
was acquired after eight months of
activity from that point they focused on
becoming better developers and
technologists working in both enterprise
environments and small successful
startups at the age of 27 he co-founded
lightrun which is on a mission to
becoming the best friend of a developer
to allow him to observe understand and
debug live applications they raised
almost 30 million dollars from great
angel investors in glenlot capital and
inside partners
ilan peleg welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm fine michael what's up thanks for
having me
oh
the episodes i love most are when i
start them with the wrong fun fact and
then i have to restart because i'm
embarrassed so now we're going to have a
really great time elon you are the
co-founder and ceo of an amazing company
light run some of the the most
incredible investors both angels and vcs
have invested more than 30 million
dollars in your company you're helping
the 2017 ability
all right
to help them and understand what's
happening in in their live applications
but more importantly than light run this
show is about leadership and
you
as a you know and as an entrepreneur as
a professional athlete as a future
entrepreneur you know you're you've had
so many experiences that i'm just
excited in the next 18 minutes or so to
to pick your brain as to what does being
a leader to you mean and and what
insights did you gain from your
different experiences and so elon it'll
be my honor if you just walk me through
your life a little bit and and how
you've experienced each of the
experiences that you've had
interesting um so again thanks for
having me basically a brief introduction
about myself um i used to be a
professional athlete back then um i
represented israel in biggest i think
international sins outdoor world
championships uh europe championships
and i had some really nice achievements
uh i retired at the age of 21 and
started my first entrepreneurial journey
with my partner leonid
my co-founder
here at lyon as well actually and we
founded honey food which was a small
israeli startup a food sharing
marketplace a home home food sharing
marketplace back then in 2013
i think there was a huge hype around
marketplaces in general sharing economy
so we found an opportunity to
take this approach into the food
industry after eight months of activity
the business was acquired
successfully i would say because it
depends how you define success i guess
we were only 21 so
it gave me the opportunity to buy a new
car
it gave me the opportunity to buy a
small new car but
uh nothing except for that financial
like financially i guess but i think the
whole experience of working together
with learning establishing something a
real company from zero building a
product it was pretty new for me and and
this is where i got excited and i
understood that
i just love building stuff and like
giving real impact for example i
remember uh one of the um childs of
one of the the cooks that we used to
work for
had a very um intimate call with me
claiming hey suddenly my mother is
earning like between 5 000 to
6 000 shekels a month
and she didn't have any income before
that um and she's doing that while she's
enjoying from you know from cooking
and it was very very
memorable moment for myself
um and from that point i think i started
thinking
bigger
um
on the other hand when we just finished
with this adventure it was pretty clear
for me and for learning that we still
want to do things together we still want
to build companies product together but
on the other hand we started
you know in focusing like what should be
the next thing and and where's our
competitive advantages because it was
pretty clear for us that food is not
that
um you know thing for us
uh but on the other hand we both loved
you know development developing
developer tooling so both got pretty
much experienced in in the field working
in startups uh successful startups which
some of them even were acquired working
in enterprise environments
so i think two years ago uh we met each
other again under not as friends but
under this entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship uh hat again and you
know founded light one and and now we
are here we are in the mission of
um i think
becoming the standard and the best
friends of developers when dealing with
observing understanding and debugging
live applications
uh so this is briefly about myself
so so now i'd like to you know
pick
pick apart and put together this journey
from the perspective of of leadership so
you know you sort of broke through the
experience of being a professional
athlete world championships
running into entrepreneurship at the age
of 21 i believe getting acquired after
eight months
having incredible you know intrinsic
motivation by with those intimate calls
where you learn that you're making an
impact on on individuals on a really
intimate level
and and now obviously with the success
of light run so far what it take me back
to the athletic part of it what was that
experience like and how do you parallel
that experience to perhaps some of the
challenges that that you know an
entrepreneur may be encountering in
their daily life
i think when i used to be there were
some similarities and some things that
were new for me like as an entrepreneur
the similarities obviously is like
i think that athletic lifestyle taught
me like self-discipline like you should
walk up
wake up every morning very early
um even if you're tired even if like
last night you had a very hard session
and like you have a mission and you will
do everything
everything required to complete it
everything um no matter how tired you
are how how how much you're suffering at
the time being you will
just find a way to win
so i think
this competitive
spirit that i've got at a pretty early
stage
uh taught me that
you know it sounds very silly but
everything is possible
i remember myself um
thinking about very ambitious goals at
the beginning of the year
and you know discussing these goals with
my coach and he said
listen i i think it's a bit ambitious
and it's no i'm gonna do so and honestly
i don't think that most of the time i
achieved this these goals but it it it
made me
work very hard and eventually when i
compared myself to others i think that
eventually i won because first there is
you know setting the the right goals
which i i must admit that within time i
became better because from time to time
i used to be
super ambitious
right and second
working very hard to achieve them so in
in in this
i think when we compare this is the
similarity but within time i i found out
myself when when i became entrepreneur
that sometimes you have people to manage
sometimes you know you have company and
and this is this is this thing was
pretty new for me because i was pretty
alone when i used to be an athlete and
and here there's some
humanity involved right you want to
create a company where people enjoy work
for when they kind of accomplish theirs
themselves and their goals so suddenly
there are other ingredients combined as
well so these were pretty
new for me
and suddenly your goals are now that
you're taking the same
are you taking the same mentality for
goal setting today
is this sort of a practice already that
you're setting goals that you may even
know are a little bit more ambitious
than perhaps feasible but that just
makes everybody work harder and and you
end up accomplishing so much more than
you would have otherwise
so you should find the balance and this
is something that i'm
you know i'm i'm
thinking about each day because
from one hand you want to aim very high
and you want you want to have very
ambitious goals because this is what
will eventually uh assist us to strive
right but on the other hand you don't
want to
make fun of yourself and and you you
want the other teammates suddenly you
are not alone to be aligned and to
believe in this mission and to believe
in these goals
so i think
my personal approach is i want to
achieve something like 80
of the goals
something like that okay so this this is
something that guides me if if i
achieved less
maybe it was too ambitious if i achieved
100 so i'm a bit upset
you understand so eighty eighty percent
uh
of the goals that i'm setting i think
it's a good practice at least this is
how i see things
i love it okay so we i'd love to spend
the next six seven minutes or so before
i have my my my questions at the end to
talk a little bit about lightroom and
the founding story of lightron more from
also a perspective of you know what what
lessons did you bring with you that
helped you you know
give it a good head start whether it be
with hiring with goal setting with with
market validation what what was it about
the beginning of light run that you
utilized your previous experience to
move forward
i think i started um
in a very engineering kind of point of
view like i remember the first uh slide
deck i prepared and one of the investors
gave me
i don't know if it's a compliment or not
but he said listen it's a very good
presentation but it's pretty obvious
that you're engineer
you understand so um i think within time
in these two years period i kind of
understood that if you really want to go
big
um you should focus on
the high level picture of how market
trends are evolving and how it will
like i think why now
is one of the greatest and most crucial
um questions that you should
first address with you with your team
and unless you have a pretty clear
and strong statement there i'm not sure
you have a business case and and and you
know you have some valid idea so
again the
i think the
the more high level the market trends
this is something that guides me through
you know the storytelling and and
approaching this is rather than the very
futuristic or or the very product wise
uh presentation kind
of story that i imagined before like
when you just started
so i think this is something that i you
know taught myself in this journey
and perhaps about you know you're
working you mentioned you're working
with leonid
and so
choosing the partnership and what was
the experience like working with
somebody you've worked with before when
a different route came back to converge
together is it was it the same as before
did you feel like you were just getting
back into rhythm or did you have to re
to reintroduce yourselves to each other
to figure out okay who are we and how
are we going to work together
yeah so i'm not sure it was clear but
basically we became friends at
like during the first journey and from
that point we kind of
you know still being in touch for for
eight or nine years
so we're going out together we were
dreaming together about
other stuff
um and and
we met each other under this the same
hat to together with under this
entrepreneurship hat but everything was
pretty smooth simply because we
again we knew each other and i think the
element here is the
trust we had
i think trust is something that nobody
speaks about or not enough in this
ecosystem but
i see lots of co-founders and their
dynamics
um from time to time i i
know i'm gathering together with some
early stage you know entrepreneurs
trying to assist them within time and i
s and and and i kind of examine the
interaction interaction between them and
the dynamics
um and and like i think we have this
kind of relationship when we can look at
each other and kind of understand each
other without even
saying anything and this is something
that you cannot like a married couple
exactly if i know though i need much
much longer time than my fiance so yeah
i love it okay so leonie tell me a
little bit about light run and not me
elon of course i feel like i'm already
talking to both you and your co-founder
at the same time
tell me a little bit about the pain
point that you've understood from an
engineering mindset about light run and
where are you headed as a company
yeah so in very very simple
words uh we as developers and i'm sure
that you kind of uh feel the same pain
um we just
didn't have
the i would say the proper way to really
debug live production environments
applications and stuff and within time
we all know that you know with the rise
of cloud native applications it simply
becomes much more complex and the gap
between development and production
widens so it's much harder to anticipate
issues in pre-prod and eventually when
there are issues it's much harder to you
know reproduce them sure so in a very
simple way
i will just mention that light one is
here to again become the best friend of
the developer when dealing with
observing understanding and debugging
live applications we kind of
developed a developer native
observability platform this is how we
call it we simply allow developers to
debug understand
live applications in the same simplicity
they do with local application that's
all um so from their id from the cli
from the you know other devtools that
where they source the code they're being
able to connect to live applications and
kind of streamline or control or manage
the same log lines metrics traces that
applications generate to better create
the image of what's the current status
of the application so we give developers
the ability to control that during
runtime and react faster
um
rather than they and so
i do just want to mention quickly that
you know as you're mentioning this to
anybody who's not an engineer it may
sound trivial and obvious that this is
something that we need and that this is
but today but it's complicated you know
there's a reason why for the last 30
years where we've been you know creating
software 40 years we we didn't have good
tools to do this and so
that that really is an an interesting
approach and you know the technological
edge here is is something really
significant to a problem that you know
any developer will immediately say hell
yes i need this right
exactly i truly feel that most of the
developers we meet when we just demo the
product there is this
aha moment like hey
of course like a light bulb yeah exactly
and this is why we aim very high we i
think this is why we kind of succeeded
during this this uh two years period
because
most of the developers when we show them
the product they are feeling the pain
at the same moment and it's very
easy
uh
in terms of messaging and positioning
because developers simply want this kind
of product so it's very easy to transfer
the message it's very easy to
like find the pain
um you know
which is very important when you're
you know having startup company fine
so
take me back a little bit now even
before you're an athlete in your
childhood what are you really curious
about what really sparks your curiosity
as you go about your day today
i was i remember myself at the early
ages very competitive it was very
important for me to be first at most of
the things i've been doing and
and within time and this is a bit
personal but within time i also learned
that you know i'm not gonna be the first
at anything i'm gonna do
so it gave me two lessons first uh find
these
you know areas where you have better con
starting conditions or preconditional or
whatever we would call it
and second again getting back to the
same point we started
setting expectations setting the right
goals is very important because i found
myself too competitive and from time to
time even when i won some competitions
if i didn't achieve my my personal goal
i found myself winning in competition
but not satisfied enough so it's a very
holistic
it's very holistic but on the same time
it's something that when i became more
and more you know mature within time
i started understand that
it's a lot about how you plan and how
you kind of
set the goals so get into this to to to
basics
i i love i i have to say that i resonate
a lot and and something that i'm working
on with myself and so on
i might pick you i might pick your brain
for some personal advice after this
episode for sure but what inspire
what inspires you today
in your day to day is it the
entrepreneurship part is it the you know
helping developers is it working with
them
what is it about your journey that
really inspires you
i think i'm gonna surprise you here um
i think my parents are my role models
actually um i think that i love what i
love about them so much and i try to
adopt is their humanity and this is yet
another thing that is different between
you know being a professional athlete
and some and becoming a leader some
you know you have a company you have
employees
and they're both smart and successful
but both of them my father is doctor my
mother is a teacher and they try to be
better every day but not from ego or
some like competitive purposes but
mainly because they believe that when
they will be better their passions
students will be better and the same for
myself when i will be a better leader
it's gonna benefit my employees and
eventually the whole company so
i think humanity is something that
drives me uh together with you know
ambitious and and and other
i love it and if there are three words
that would describe you or less or more
non-committing what would those words be
um i think the first one is
i i think i'm a fast learner i think
it's a very
important characteristic um about
entrepreneurship
uh i'm a hustler
and i think i'm hungry i'm ambitious um
i strive to be better at each day and
and i work very hard
to achieve that so this is also the
culture that they kind of
try to you know
to submit here at leicester
ilan
i can't wait to see what happens with
lightrun
and thank you thank you for the
inspiration and for the time and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you very
much thank you very much mikhail thank
you see you i hope to see you very soon
in our office by the way are very much
welcome
i'll take on the invitation thank you
bye bye
[Music]